ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States
[Applause]
okay everyone calm down
and don't panic as you know only a few
hours ago I was in Paris with President
Emmanuel Lewis macaroni and it
beautifully fit tight white that's the
kind of hotter you find in Paris not
Pittsburgh let me tell you but the
events of the past few days have forced
me to return home to update you on the
status of this terrible outbreak what
outbreak the horrible virus that has
infected the brains of millions of
people forcing them to believe bogus
ridiculous well documented things about
me and Russia some know it as Kremlin
flu Enza to others it's Moscow disease
and to an unlucky few it's spiraea
those aren't diseases yes they are I'm
wearing the science coat it's spread
through fake news media and I alone can
fix it now don't worry we're going to
contain this outbreak because tonight's
theme is containment I want to ask you
about your son my son Erik thank you so
much for asking he's doing so great
clear eyes soft gums can't lose I know
your other son Jared of course Donald Jr
well in a way Jared is the junior I
never Donald
those emails prove that your son met
with a surrogate of the Russian
government no parent wants to talk about
their firstborn your firstborn is like
the first pancake it's Miss shapen it's
a disappointment and you wish you hadn't
named it after yourself you named your
pancakes keep I picked ice out of your
mouth
now everyone barricade your doors
convert all your assets for gold
and throw your loved ones under the bus
I'm the president
Kalu believe it let's roll